olá meu nome é marco e eu tenho 24 anos
há 12 anos atrás estava sentado à porta
de uma consulta em lisboa pela primeira
vez tinha ficado de fora da consulta e
quando os meus pais saíram nesta
consulta
eu vi algo que nenhum de 12 a 13 antes
viver eu vi na cara de deus num
sentimento de dor e de frustração de
impotência e na dita que em teoria vez a
três meses eu estava numa cadeira de
rodas
o desenvolvimento da vida normalmente
demora 40 semanas pretendam semanas
eu tive um mau cheiro se viver com 27
sou uma pessoa curiosa e nove meses que
nem são caras
não só isso e então se fizerem um
esforço de imaginação comigo
se pensarem um pouco de açúcar
companhias brasil é era eu
eu não vim sozinho vim com meu irmão
gêmeo fábio que acabou por falecer
devido a um vídeo que se instalou na
eventual ação das incubadoras não estava
e quero que saibas que te agradeço do
fundo do coração com a força toda a
coragem e toda a determinação que ainda
hoje transmite bom
muito obrigado a própria também que dodô
vir se instalou a eram fazer transfusões
de sangue e essas transições de sangue
tinham de ser feitas nas vaias da cabeça
porque ele vá a situação e nós sempre
promotur eram as únicas vai acelerar
antes que o suficiente
e apesar de todo o cuidado e sendo me
interessa muito a escala
alguma coisa não correu muito bem e veio
num este tempo todo com que agora
apresenta aqui pra mim isto é o meu
sangue natural ii e entra aqui é a
primeira lição de vida que eu quero que
vocês levem desta troca para a vossa
casa também toca e ea solução é não
jogar não culpem a gente está a fazer o
melhor que pode
com as ferramentas que tem lá a sua
constância e hoje posso dizer que não
sente qualquer ressentimento com o que
se passou com a minha todo dia e criei
aqui também um agradecimento público a
equipe que tratou de mim eu falei
naquela altura porque aí vai
o complicada a situação podia ser e foi
diagnóstico clínico
chama-se para a europa onde pede às
partes e estuprar uma criança podia ser
algo muito complicado e eu digo que
podia falar porque por pra mim não foi
eu uma criança é alegria uma criança é a
felicidade de uma criança para ela não
não existem limitações não existem
barreiras não está em caixa uma criança
feliz aquilo era nepote nina eu tive de
aprender e passar pelas batalhas da vida
como vocês também tiveram tive de
aprender a gatinhar tive de reaprender a
andar pra mim tudo super normal e chato
que quando anita vai à praia
[Aplausos]
muito obrigado é a partida que foram
foram 12 anos de trabalho físico muito
intensa fisioterapia quase diária com
minha mãe incansavelmente sa a eles para
lisboa mas como diz fora isso sem
limitações porque não se sentiam sentia
normal a partir deste momento começa a
dar uma volta de 180 graus e
fornecimento aos 12 13 anos que os meus
pais vão consultório médico e vi ele
dizendo que eu iria provocar a copa
vicar em portugal não havia mais nada a
fazer né estava em que pra mim não
desistir nunca foi a opção nunca será
e para os meus pais também não e então
começamos a procurar alternativas no
estrangeiro
estrangeiro e havia cuba cuba para este
caso é muito conhecidos a era mais
fisioterapia mais do mesmo e o que
acontecer provavelmente era quando os
adversários a situação podia querer vir
depois estados unidos havia uma pressão
mas que era financeiramente
incomportável para nós e era muito muito
arriscada
então a opção que sobrou foi uma clínica
ortopédica na online como desenhos ou
mãe que havia vamos lá vamos ver o que o
que sair daqui e eu tenho vindo a única
com dois é parar de comer chama de ajuda
a locução ea condição seria que eu tinha
de usar diariamente o máximo tempo
possível e nunca era pra mim tá
independência era para é enviar essa tá
nem aí para a cadeira de rodas porque
estava num momento em que eu tinha dores
é exportável que começaram apostadores
não sabia daquelas vinho e tenha evitar
a tal moda para a cadeira de rodas foi
uma solução srs que surgiu então você
está em robocop o dia sentindo marcou
quer dizer eu eu sair daqui
a entrada nas separações que eu tenho
usado diariamente e os limitavam o que
devia ser uma rotina saudável e normal
de uma criança eu queria ir à praia
calçaram as havaianas não queria criar
correr criança cria tomar banho em pepe
coisas mais simples não conseguia eu
acendia mutualmente preso à noite quando
todas as pessoas querem dormir e
descansar
eu era obrigada dormir com este paraíso
elza é basicamente avião os velcros
chavão na perna e 11 1 desde a até lá
vai e eu tinha de dormir toda noite com
estes e paraty
escusado será dizer que os dois eram um
insuportável vez muitas vezes vai para
falar aí acordei a maçaneta soar não
dizer aos meus pais porque seria o
esforço financeiro que estava a ser
feito ea minha vida a partir daqui dois
três até aos meus 20 anos de uma forma
de controle de 10 dias sentia preso à
noite senti empresa
as notas que era um refúgio que eu tinha
começaram a ir por água mas em casa
naturalmente o ambiente refletia toda a
exigência da situação eo que estava a
passar em termos de relacionamentos
interpessoais para encostar em mente uma
voz na nossa cabeça de execuções como
aquelas entre os presos tratados
estas ajudas a estes senhores
foi uma situação muito dura e eu não
soube por um buraco negro chegava a casa
e todos os dias com a sensação dizer
fogo eu tô forte estar neste corpo eu
quero sair do meu corpo eu tenho a ver
algo mais sem ser visto e nos dias em
que precisar eu parecia não terminar de
que já não via há muita luz ao fundo do
túnel
eu penso aí vai mas se calhar este
pensamento que eu ter eu quero ser este
o corpo quer dizer que ou então não
estou limitado a este corpo quem é este
eu que está cá dentro que diz que quer
sair do corpo onde é que ela vai calhar
eu não tentar limitar num
escalar eu posso usar o meu corpo como
ferramenta para permitir ultrapassar os
obstáculos se calhar eu consigo mudar
comigo aqui um pensamento diferente
apareceu na minha cabeça se calhar podem
haver mais de si e podemos ver o que o
que pode fazer e então a marca eu era
pensar que é o corpo marca então olha
embora ginásio e eu não tinha noção do
impacto que é parceiro robocop no
ginásio e eu tenho os profissionais do
exercício físico e aqui outra altura de
maior talvez escuridão na minha vida que
foi chegar ao ginásio e pai e do tio
enquanto as portas na cara diziam não
porque não sabemos como é que vamos
trabalhar contigo
não porque os méritos ao menino com medo
por causa das suas articulações
não porque simplesmente temos mesmo e
aqui eu quero deixar outra mensagem da
minha top que é que parece escuro
normalmente é aí que depois da
tempestade vem a bonança não costuma
viver na minha vida
essa tem um nome tem nome chama-se
daniel o domingo é um técnico que se o
físico é um enfermeiro especial está em
reabilitação corporal acho que isso vai
na verdade eu não sei bem como é que eu
explico que quer usar nem a ninguém mas
eu acho que eu pra mim é um anjo da
guarda em part-time então depois
daquelas nós todos eu usar nem olha pra
mim e dizer eu estou muito excitado não
sei como é que vou trabalhar contigo e
com um brilho nos olhos enorme desafio
uma escultura coragem é pa quer dizer
que não vamos vamos treinar e união
começa a ler os relatórios médicos que
eu tinha da alemanha e ao desenho que a
razão pela qual eu usava os aparelhos do
dia era porque não tinha estrutura
muscular suficiente para aguentar o
próprio peso do meu corpo e então a
partir deste momento nós temos uma meta
que é um marco vamos tirar os aparelhos
a estrutura muscular
vamos ganhar lá e e eu não vou mentir no
primeiro tempo que foi eu não sou de
minas faz nega
e eu chegava a sttrans e eu caí a com o
peso do meu corpo
sozinho ah eu não aguentava meu corpo
não tinha força para aguentar o meu
próprio corpo
imaginem a revolta que é mas eu tive
alguém que pegou em mim com coração
aberto e sim o amor pode mudar uma vida
do mi6 não marcamos e tu vais conseguir
isto é mais que isto
então foi pequenas vitórias e o melhor
dia da minha vida foi o dia em que eu
não treino
o daniel me aguentei sozinho pela
primeira vez sozinho era liberdade
liberdade é a liberdade de fazer as
pequenas coisas e ir à praia calma as
havaianas bolas eu conseguir uma vaga em
pé
uau eu consegui sair à noite conseguir
lançar em para maravilha
fiz a corrida do xingu sair mafra uma
correria aqui a ação seis quilômetros em
fila e cortar a meta ao lado do dna
sempre que eu era menor e na verdade as
adoções nesse trabalho com daniel
eu consegui retirar os aparelhos pra
sempre
não uso os noite também não se
influenciar de usar e estão em casa a
ganhar pó é pena que não dá pra vender
lamento porque são só meus a então
pronto está no al sadd horários que não
sabe o que faz xixi e eu é prevenir
na minha curta vida já aprendi alguma
coisa e eu quero deixar aqui com duas
versões finais na minha toca uma rosa é
algo dentro de vocês quando tudo parece
errado quando toda a gente faz diz que
não quando a gente dizer pa
não é por aqui não consegue isto vai te
fazer mal ao e vocês nem todos vocês em
cada um de vocês que é tão maior do que
as nossas limitações físicas do que a
vossa sozinho na cabeça e sintoniza que
não dá e que não é capaz por favor faça
um favor por mim tá chegando em casa tem
um tempo só para vocês vão descobrir a
sua essência o que estão aqui fazer o
que com limitações e que tem prazo pra
nossa vida e não em ganhar
volta e vão ser frio eu não sei se é tão
bonita
por favor que encontrei na tabela e na
segunda lição que eu tenho é é acreditar
no amor por quanto parece mais difícil o
amor aparece na vossa vida mesmo que não
vai jogar
por favor então se não ouvirem saiju no
tendão alguém um sorriso às vezes gosto
pouco fazemos o amor acontecer custa
pouco sermos humano e por favor
acreditem todos nós aqui querendo chamar
de todos nós aqui temos muito amor
provar por favor saírem desta talks leva
esta mensagem se espalhe o amor favor
espalhem a felicidade para a alegria de
tristeza estava muito chá
não precisamos mais e quero só deixar o
iraque como uma mensagem final que é uma
mensagem final de gratidão gratidão às
pessoas que fazem ver o mundo
perspectivas é gratidão aos amigos
fantásticos que eu tenho as obras
maravilhosas que eu tenho a volta da
energia e gratidão essencialmente os
grandes privados de dívida que são os
meus pais estão aqui hoje vê nesta toca
uma salva de palmas para os fácil
[Aplausos]
e só para o terminar a lembrança
insistam precisão e nunca desistam
obrigados e agora sim vou fazer um
caldeirão fim de semana no topo
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]